So you're all comfortable
with your home directory, but
surely there's more to this
computer than just that.
Right?
Oh yeah, there is a lot more.
So let's start exploring some
of the other areas of the Linux
operating system.
We'll do this by cding to the top
level root folder with cd /.
If we ls -al this directory, we'll see
that there's a lot of content here.
We're definitely not going to
cover all of these, but
we'll discuss the most
important folders.
We're already familiar with home,
but there are two other important
directories where you'll be making
lots of changes and editing files.
Etc is where configuration files live.
As we start setting up our web and
database server, we'll be modifying
some files within this directory.
Var is for variable files.
Which is kind of an odd name.
Variable files are simply files
that you expect to grow or
change in size over time.
You'll typically find system and
application logs within this directory.
There are a few other directories that
are that are important for you to know,
but you probably won't be modifying or
directly interacting with them.
Bin is where executable
binaries are stored,
that are accessible by all users.
These are applications that you run,
like the LS command we've
used a few times already.
If you were to list
the contents of this directory,
you would actually see there's
a file called LS within it.
SBin is very similar to bin, except
that these binaries are to only be
used by the route user for system
administration and maintenance purposes.
We'll discuss some of the applications
within this directory a bit later.
Lib is for
libraries that support the binaries
that are located around the system.
Finally, usr is for user programs.
This could seem a bit confusing
compared to the bin directory.
The difference isn't that important.
The only difference really is that
the binaries within bin are required for
a boot-up and
system maintenance processes,
and the binaries in usr necessarily
aren't required for that.